hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
Marvel just announced sweeping changes
coming to the Marvel comic book universe
most hardcore comic fans were really
pissed but I wanted to explain how the
movies have started to influence the way
that they think about the comics it's
not completely responsible for why
they're changing the Marvel comic book
universe but it has something to do with
it
quick explanation of what's going on
Marvel is rebooting their comic book
universe it's like the Train is stopping
at a station a bunch of comic book
readers will hate it totally get off the
train a bunch of new people will jump on
they'll use it as a point to start
reading the comics they're starting with
a whole new continuity after their big
Secret Wars comic Secret Wars is the
name of the big storyline that's gonna
run this summer if you've never read
comics before I'd recommend checking it
out if you if you don't want to pay for
comics if you don't have money you can
get Marvel unlimited it's super cheap
and six months after it comes out you
can read it for almost free mostly it's
meant to clean house the Marvel Universe
in the comics is just all over the place
there's so much going on there's so many
changes that have happened and now they
have all the movies and it's it's like
this billion-dollar industry they want
to make things line up so they're just
taking an opportunity to make it all
sync up a little bit better that doesn't
mean that the comics are going to be
exactly like the movies or the movies
are going to be exactly like the comics
it'll always be largely independent it's
just that they'll make character
backstories the same and you'll see more
characters from the movies appearing in
the mainstream comics it'll also help
them sidestep some of the issues with
like multiple versions of say like
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch running
around in the movies and TV shows
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch are just
the best example like there's x-men
movie versions of their characters and
now there's gonna be Avengers versions
of their characters it's really
confusing so Marvel is just trying to
clean house a little bit one of the best
ways to explain that in the basis of
this video is Avengers age of Ultron
you have the movie coming out in a
couple months we're all really pumped
for but there's also a comic book
age of Ultron from 2013 from a couple
years ago the story that they're gonna
do in the movie and the story that they
did in that comic book completely
separate have absolutely zero to do with
each other so just so I can explain
things a little bit better careful for
spoilers from the age of Ultron comic
book story from 2013 in an alternate
Ultron's taken over the world using a
form of time travel in the process of
fixing things
Wolverine shatters the space-time
continuum creating a separate timeline
that's partly responsible for the
craziness that's going on in the market
so the movie you know as you've seen is
only gonna have like a fraction of the
number of characters from that comic
book and the story is gonna be way way
simpler so like all the crap that
happened to the Avengers in the comic
book
age of Ultron has absolutely nothing to
do with what's gonna happen to the
Avengers in the age of Ultron movie it's
just a good example of how the comics
have always been completely separate
from the movies TV shows other media
so all that separate-but-equal stuff
changed a couple years ago no more
segregation in the Marvel Universe at
least on the surface level after the
first Avengers movie came out it became
proof that on the corporate level you
can plan movies out this far in advance
and it'll work it's a good financial
model and then you sidestep to companies
like Fox who are trying to do the same
thing with the x-men universe so Marvel
and Disney are adjusting things again
now with this new big comic book reboot
to bring everything a lot closer make it
simpler to follow and make it fit within
the Marvel Cinematic Universe just a
little bit that doesn't mean that the
comics are gonna be exactly like the
movies like I said it just means they'll
be a little bit more continuity with the
character backstories based on the IP
that Marvel owns across film print and
TV and really at the end of the day
what's happening is you're seeing
original characters from the movies
ending up in the mainstream comics Agent
Coulson is the first example of that the
first big example normally it flow in
the opposite direction like you have a
comic book character that ends up in a
movie just this year though they started
doing comics based on the TV shows so
there's an agents of shield comic book
featuring the characters from the TV
show if it's successful it's an ongoing
comic if it's successful they'll
probably do the same thing with the
Peggy Carter show with agent Carter they
did do an original sin tie-in comic with
her and Howard Stark like a story but
it's not an ongoing comic I have been
reading the agents of shield comic it's
okay like but if you don't have enough
money to buy new comics all the time
just get Marvel unlimited and read it
six months later and you can read it for
almost next to nothing like it's almost
free seriously the latest big example of
the movies influencing the comic books
is a couple of changes they made to the
quick
and Scarlet Witch characters so just
minor spoilers for Avengers x-men access
for that comic book storyline so in the
comic book I mean it's mostly a Red
Skull story where he makes Chico crazy
as a result of that it's discovered that
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch are not
Magneto's true children that was like a
huge retcon big WTF but you can see why
Marvel might want to make the
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch of their
comics closer to the versions of the
characters that they're doing in the
movies they're never gonna get the x-men
characters back just based on the
contract that Fox has with x-men IP as
long as they continue to make x-men
films they can keep making x-men films
indefinitely so Marvel is just baking on
the fact that they're never gonna get
x-men back so just to make things less
confusing for people that might read the
comics in the future they want to make
the Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
characters seem more like the characters
that people see in the movies because
nowadays it's the movies that are really
driving comic book sales so what you
have is you have like a lot of people
who've never read a comic before they'll
go see Avengers age of Ultron and
they'll say hey I want to read about
these characters in the comics and then
they'll go out and look for them but
they'll have these really complicated
backstories that have absolutely nothing
to do with the characters in the movies
so Marvel just trying to make things a
little bit simpler that's like on the
unescape the big universe reboot they're
doing that's more of a specific comic
book thing just to make their continuity
lineup they just have the multiverse and
they have so many different versions of
characters they just want to make it
simpler and they're also just taking the
opportunity to you know bring the movies
and the comic books it's a little bit
closer most of the changes Marvel is
making won't really play out until after
Secret Wars this summer so I'm kind of
wait - give anything thumbs up thumbs
down until after I read some of those
new comic book titles with the new
continuity they're gonna keep making the
movies no matter what they'll keep
making the comics no matter what so
worst case scenario you just bail on the
comics for a couple years till Marvel
reboots everything again
seriously Marvel DC they've changed
their comic book continuity a ton of
times over the years they're gonna keep
doing it like I said the people that
will be affected by this most are the
people that have been reading comics
like a lot of comics for the past like
20 or 30 years so it'll be a bit of an
adjustment but if you're a huge Marvel
fan then eventually you'll get used to
it it'll look a lot more like the DC
Universe does right now not not in terms
of characters I'm not I'm not trying to
imply that they're going to
the characters look like the DC
characters it's just in the way that the
universe works with like a shared
continuity I think a lot of people are
just worried with Disney taking over
Marvel and trying to make everything
connected it's all gonna get homogenized
and watered down and everything will
look the same here's my big question for
you guys do you care that they're
completely changing the continuity of
the Marvel comic books and do you like
that they're trying to tie it into the
movies just a little bit more you know I
mean it's not gonna cross over directly
but the characters will share some
continuity in terms of backstories so
moving along to Marvel related stuff I
know a lot of you guys have requested
Black Panther videos so I think my next
video will probably be like a black
panther or character video he's gonna be
one of the big movies Marc Guggenheim
who's the showrunner on arrow was even
joking how he wanted to write the script
for that I don't know that he would have
time to do that because being a
showrunner on a show that shoots over
180 days a year is like the full time
job for two separate people crammed into
one person's job in case you didn't know
he's actually married to one of the show
runners on agent Carter so you have like
a lot of Marvel DC under the same roof
although Marc Guggenheim himself does
write a lot of Marvel comics if you do
have any other like special requests for
Marvel videos just let me know in the
comments in a couple weeks Constantine
will go away I'll have a little bit more
time in my schedules like you know
fridays through saturdays at least until
game of thrones gets here so i will have
some opportunities to do some other
bonus video some other fun stuff that i
don't normally do
so what you guys wait for my next Marvel
video you can actually click here for my
last Q&A I go a little bit deeper into
the Ultron trailer and talk about like
who that mystery person might be and you
can click here for my top five Ultron
stories from the comics thank you so
much for watching so that's all high
five I'll see you guys this weekend
you